didn't the climate change before humans
came around absolutely the earth's
climate is constantly changing and has
undergone many swings over the past
billion years the average temperature of
the Earth has been as much as 14° C
warmer than it currently is as it was
500 million years ago and has also been
as much as 6° colder than it currently
is these changes were caused by natural
factors in particular variations in the
level of carbon dioxide in the Earth's
atmosphere caused by volcanic eruptions
and geological weathering and in changes
in the Earth's orbit around the sun C
milanovich Cycles the key thing is that
these changes were relatively slow
varying the Earth's temperature by a few
degrees over thousands and thousands of
years and they continue to this day but
the warming we observe at present is
blisteringly Fast by comparison the
warming we've experienced since 1981
would warm the Earth by 18° C in just a
thousand years that's so much faster
than anything in the geological record
the mechanism of this warming is the
same as some of the previous changes in
temperature changes in the level of CO2
in our atmosphere the two key
differences are the speed and where that
carbon is coming from not volcanoes or
weathering but us